(audience applauding)
- All right,
welcome back everybody.
After a heated game of A Quiet Case,
back with The Chicks,
everybody give it up for them.
(Kelly and audience applauding)
And we're also still hanging out with
(audience applauding)
Matt Iseman,
host of "American Ninja Warriors",
which begins a new season
this evening on NBC.
(audience applauding)
So, had y'all ever met before?
- We hadn't and I'd been a fan,
but it was cool watching
them just destroy you
and be heartless about it.
- You know what, sir?
- Because they seem so nice.
(all laughing)
- I can't wait to
kick your behind after the show.
You are my friend, sir.
So wait, so you're from Denver.
- Yeah.
- I actually didn't remember
that you were from Colorado.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's awesome.
So, how often do you get back to Denver?
Do you ever get back?
- I get back
probably seven or eight times a year.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's good.
- I've found this place,
five star service to stay at.
It's my parents' house.
(all laughing)
It is, it is incredible.
I go back there and this,
so my childhood bedroom
is unchanged since June
of '89, when I graduated
from high school.
- What?
- Oh my.
- It is a time capsule.
- Wow.
- You open the door,
you can smell the Drakkar Noir, it is-
(all laughing)
And so, that's, this was across,
this has been across
from my bed since '86.
Every night, it's Arnold,
♪ Go to sleep ♪
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God, wait,
and "Predator", that was that (growling),
that sound, yeah.
- Yeah, that was it,
that was it.
- I love "Predator".
- And now we're friends,
and every time I tell him,
"I had your poster on my bedroom wall",
he's like, "That's not even
creepy a little bit, Iseman.
(all laughing)
I wish I would've had your
poster on my bedroom wall."
- [Kelly] (laughing) That
is an amazing impression!
- Oh, it's something, my mom,
people will come to the house and they go,
"Oh, it's like you have
a 13 year old son."
I'm like, I do stand up comedy
and talk about ninjas, you kinda do, Mom.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my gosh,
that's amazing.
- Yeah.
- People would love that.
What kind of posters did y'all have?
- Hmm, my whole wall
above my bed was Bon Jovi-
- Oh!
- Bon Jovi and Sebastian Bach.
(Natalie and audience laughing)
- Oh my God, I love that.
- The greatest front man
of a heavy metal band of all time.
I remember the year that-
- And some Axl Rose.
I had some Axl Rose.
- I love Axl,
Guns and Roses, well, what about y'all?
- Jim Morrison-
- Oh.
was in silk, above my bed.
(all laughing)
- Love it.
What about you?
- I had Adam Ant and some banjo
players, which is so lame.
(all laughing)
- I love that,
I love that.
- [Matt] Steve Martin is
nodding along right now.
- Yeah.
- I don't believe
banjo players had posters.
- Bon Jovi.
- They had posters.
- His hair was amazing in the '80s.
- Oh yeah, very good.
- Still.
- It is still amazing.
- Okay, so what's going
on, it's season 14, right?
- [Matt] Yes.
- So, what's happening that's different
in "American Ninja Warrior"?
- Well, it just keeps getting bigger.
It keeps getting harder,
and they keep figuring
out a way to get through it.
We, last season, we lowered the age to 15
to get on the show.
- Oh, so you have kids like
kicking adults behinds?
- They are, Kelly!
(Kelly laughing)
It is, I mean-
- That is so sad.
- I feel so old, and a rotary phone.
They're like, what is a phone at home?
I've only had cell phones.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, right?
- But they're, it's amazing
seeing them come out,
handle the pressure of
being in front of millions
of people watching at home.
But, even the stories we
hear, there was a kid,
Christopher Harding Jones,
this unbelievable story.
He has a sensory processing disorder,
but his dad was diagnosed with
lung cancer six years ago,
given six months to live.
And the dad said, "I can't
control how long I live
but I can control how wide I live.
I wanna live wide and do everything."
And the dad ended up being
around for three years,
but passed away, and the kid just said,
"Growing up I always
watched "Ninja Warrior",
and I thought, I wanna live
wide, I want to go try this."
So he's out there-
- What a legacy-
- Running on the show-
- To leave behind.
- But keeping his
dad's memory alive.
- Yeah.
- And for so many people,
I think, who are
confronted with, you know,
our own mortality, that idea of, you know,
there are ways you live
on past your time here
by by how you influence people.
And I thought it was
just a beautiful message.
- Yeah.
- I get to,
I must have cried 23 times this season.
We had two proposals, both yeses.
It's really cool being a part of a show
where the performances on the course
are just the beginning and-
- Yeah.
- The obstacles
people overcome in life, we, you know,
particularly during this pandemic,
I think we've all been
confronted with the challenges,
but seeing how some people
just choose to fight-
- Overcome.
- And overcome it.
- Yeah.
- And I think it's so inspiring,
now I'm not working out,
but it does inspire you.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
It does inspire you, I'm not gonna,
I'm not getting carried away.
- (laughing) I love that though,
that they, you can see
people, like how we,
you see humanity like
really push themselves
and see what we're capable of.
It's really cool.
- It is, and I think
that's what we've needed,
is this idea of you see
someone do something and,
what's cool is when they
surprise themselves,
and do something that
maybe they didn't even know
what they're capable of.
And I think especially
for the young kids-
- Sense of accomplishment.
- You see them have a moment
that could shape the rest of their lives.